18h16 une émission tout en musique cas
jusqu'à 19h dans culture première nous
accueillons donc christophe sur gonesse
mathieu brillante pour évoquer leur
carte blanche avec un groupe mythique
sabouk deux autres artistes sur le
plateau benjam avec autrement sortie fin
2016 est il une qu'on attend avec
confidences deux albums aux styles
différents mais mais on en reparle dans
cette émission culture première avec
jean paul mellars bonsoir christophe bon
sur matthieu monceaux apple alors un
projet avec ce bouquin en congé marquer
un project avec sa bourgue faut-il
encore présenter sa boucle ce groupe des
années 90 avec le chanteur gérard encore
un titre qui reste dans les mémoires
bien sûr racines christophe j'ai encore
marqué christopher c'est christophe
lyonnaise qui en sortira
kind of blue l'année dernière et déjà
vous vous mariez tous les deux ça book
enfin oisiens scène bien comment comment
est née cette union voilà autour d'un
verre un toujours d'accord
non c'était kiki qu'avait qui avait émis
l'idée un petit peu jusqu'au plateau
artistique
du coup comme mathieu et moins on joue
dans sa bouquet et que ausone ccc aussi
mathieu et zoug au projet que c'est
moins donc à l'idée de voilà de de
partager les fonds de partage un peu de
musique est présenté tout ça parce
qu'ils adorent btan ceux qui répondent
déjà aux questions que j'allais poser
c'est parfait tout d'un coup bang a pris
plus rien à dire' ficcadenti fait
démissionner jeu et je m'en vais alors
oui alors donc aux autres je ne savais
pas que c'était mathieu briand sur la
journée poser la question donc c'est lui
alors bon zogo zogo projets axés quoi
c'est kind of blue
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui aura comme
mélange enfin c'est exactement
exactement au projet que ces cailloux ce
soit en âge argana tour a précisé ses
voix la can you c'est mon album qui est
sorti le 1er juin 2015
soula
la musique production et donc du coup
fois cette soirée-là du 31 mars
voilà je vais jouer et interpréter des
morceaux de l'album est présenté un
petit peu d'accord il ya mathieu briand
d'un côté il y a kiki maria plein de
l'autre il n'y aura pas que du
christophe sur gonesse n'y aura pas que
du match brillant et pas que du sabot
alors ça va donner quoi au final l'urd
et des morceaux communs à l'un et à l'or
et aux uns et aux autres
quelques caisses qui aura deux
d'original si je puis dire ça comme ça
mathieu briand à c'est pour moi alors
bah oui parce qu'il fait signer ses
potes en fait ce qui est intéressant de
cette soirée vraiment c'est qu'il ya
quand même une un ensemble de génération
de musiciens aussi on sera quand même 11
11 11 en usi séance musiciens sur scène
et aux jeunes
c'est quelque chose qui vient de moi à
la base effectivement dans l'idée mais
en fait on est quatre il y aura là alors
je peux je peux annoncer parce que je
pense que je veux faire le laurent
ognard auchan lui d'opérer sa batterie
christophe qui sera avec moi aussi et
mon clavier
une petite jeune génération de musiciens
qui va commencer ensuite christophe de
gonesse qui va enchaîner qu'il
présentait un jazz fusion avec des des
musiciens quand même assez expérimenté
avec lui eh bien on va terminer par
sabouk vous des 10 a marqué l'histoire
donc je trouve je trouve que c'est on
est dans le même team musicale dans le
jazz la fusion la world music
mais avec un ensemble de musiciens de
toutes générations et je trouve ça
intéressant comme idée de partager ça
sur scène voilà alors avant qu'un
continuons à demander comment benjam de
nous ferez facebook là il faudrait qu'il
y ait parce que comme chez fait je suis
moins et vous pouvez faire aussi set dj
ça fait deux ça fait de la publicité est
pour vous et pour des missions donc il
ya des jeunes enfin une jeune génération
c'est ce que vous disais à l'instant
mathieu ça veut dire quoi c'est des
jeunes qui une vingtaine d'années dont
on va dire oui entre entre 25 et entre
25 et 35
voilà moi moi personnellement j'écoute
et sabu quoi j'étais très petit hmm hmm
bébés presque est aujourd'hui joue avec
sa beauté partager une scène et que ça
book c'est juste c'est juste formidable
c'est juste moi ou comme des jeunes
c'est juste warcq ans qui m'a appelé en
2010 pour remonter le groupe sa boucle
j'ai vécu ça comme quelque chose
d'exceptionnel j'ai dit oui sans hésiter
ça a demandé du travail et sept ans plus
tard en 2017 on se retrouve à refaire a
continué sa et a partagé la scène même
avec d'autres projets donc le tout
moment ça là on est vraiment dans le
partage dans le plaisir et je pense
qu'on va passer une bonne soirée
il ya eu des choix j'allais dire un peu
pas draconien mais difficile pour les
morceaux à choisir christopher gunness
ou est-ce que ça s'est fait
naturellement on s'est dit moi je prends
ça ça ça ça
chacun fait sa partition et puis on est
d'accord on fera un truc comme avions
alors comment ça s'est passé c'est pas
facile sortez votre téléphone vous
mathieu brodeur que c'est pas facile
d'imaginer
spectacle comme ça avec trois groupes
différents il faut que les morceaux
s'enchaînent qu'il faut absolument se
soient dynamiques et que les morceaux
soient cohérents par rapport aux trois
groupes
donc c'est pas évident d'organiser ça
mais
voilà pour ma part moi c'est des
morceaux qui envoie est qui qui sont
assez dynamiques c'est festif
donc on peut me l'annoncer dessus voilà
est ce que vaut évidemment je pose la
question qui est pas évidente pour moi
est ce que byd a évidemment le moronou
racine sera jouée et peut-être revisité
alors le racing le racine il sera
revisitée il sera inédit voilà ça fasse
un peu un peu le standard deçà bouquin
racines bien sûr quand ça book sort en
concerne oui quasiment ccg comment je me
semblait et à chaque fois on leur visite
voilà c'est comme ça ment soit c'est
jazzy jazz même voilà une part belle à
l'improvisation et à la nouveauté à
chaque fois donc alors mathieu surpris
alors mathieu il ya un instant que bons
ballons il était petit lorsqu'il a
entendu ce morceau et c'est le cas aussi
pour vous étiez petit quand il s'adresse
à beaucoup un peu plus vieux j'étais
petit un peu plus je un peu plus que
mathieu mais oui j'entends des saab ou
que je connaissais un peu les musiciens
et pour moi et c'était quand même
un groupe mythique des années 90 et
voilà lorsque lorsque climat appelé qui
m'a appelé qui m'arrive
voilà comment alors comment ça se passe
les répétitions a comme vous êtes quand
même nombreux il faut il faut il faut
gérer
il faut bien ça demande de la répétition
varie pas comme ça sur scène en disant
ouais bah moi je connais les morceaux
étoiles il ya un ensemble sabouk ses
sept musiciens
voilà dès qu'ils sont eux qui sont
dessus kiki maria pain à la basse
dominique si l'un à la batterie bebert
maria pain aux percussions le cousin
parce que je pense et le frère voilà ce
qu'à un autre ça la source pour ça
qu'elle aussi ça je crois hélas par tous
et les gangs démarré à terre comme des
variables
j'ai rarement car au chant lead mathieu
briand au clavier il a quand même une
voix particulière j'ai vraiment encore
enfin se passer quelque chose c'est un
truc qui reste pas c'est oui exactement
c'est une voie ou voilà il dit deux mots
et une histoire racontée voilà voilà
comment ça l'histoire est racontée et
puis c'est prenant voilà cependant on
s'amuse à nous excuser
alors dites-moi est-ce que mathieu
briand oui en fait de christophe
présentez-nous mathieu briand parce que
moi je le connais pas beaucoup j'avoue
très très honnêtement je les vis tu
regardais ça sa bio
apparemment c'est un brillant
il porte bien son nom est ce que tu vas
dire non en fait mathieu on s'est
rencontré un petit peu moi j'étais
j'avais fait s'étend sur paris et
m'avait contacté pour un concert de
mathieu tu te rappelles de saint louis
s'est pas fait d'ailleurs un super
concert à la scène bastille en grosses
scènes à paris et il m'a contacté il
m'avait demandé si j'étais bispo et tout
est là oui je suis dit waouh mathieu
briand waouh c'est quand même il avait
sorti un super album my dinh maloya
c'était en 2010 2011
ah ouais d'accord déjà et voilà moi
c'était un musicien que je suivais de
loin même à 10 micromètres je suivais
son parcours et j'ai mis beaucoup ça
voilà ce qu'il a apporté sa musique sa
la fusion et ce mot fusion pour
revendiquer enfin j'entends souvent
world fusion maloya fusion aller à dire
du jazz fusion ce que vous connaissez
certainement mais revendiqué un match
brillant le prix palissy moi je filme
moi d'accord non fusion - honnêtement
fusion je l'entends très simplement
comme mélanger d'accord fusion il ya
beaucoup de 10 à tout type de fusion
jazz fusion avec des influences jazz
bien sûr mais a pris finalement la
fusion c'est un mélange un mélange de
plein de choses c'est un mélange de tout
tout style
donc c'est un gros mélange voilà alors
d'aider des jeunes de votre génération
de la trentaine de qui font du jazz y en
a beaucoup sur l'eau sur 9,1
je pense que jean charest ne cherchait
un genre j'en ai un tel jeu voit son
visage mais je me souviens il ya
beaucoup il ya toujours eu
c'est la réunion il ya quand même des
super musiciens des saints qui ces
sports des musiciens qui se forme aussi
à paris des musiciens qui se forment aux
états unis donc avisé que sa fin aux
etats unis c'est pas assez konaté au t
shirt et hoarau qui vont faire la nuit
des vieilles choses là aussi beaucoup
cet événement donc voilà il ya une école
aussi qu'ils essaient ouverte aussi
qu'il ya beaucoup développé sa cdma
réunion donc une école de musique
actuelle et qui permet de former des
musiciens sur la réunion sur l'océan
indien que les jeunes de l'ema était
chez notre animateur david mentaux je
crois que là c'était la semaine dernière
mais voilà je me trompe pas ils étaient
une dizaine ils étaient venus est en
effet c'est il ya de bons de bon bon bon
produit toujours de bons musiciens des
talents qu'on découvre à chaque fois et
c'est voilà c'est un vivier à la réunion
que ça soit le madagascar maurice et
l'océan indien était vraiment vous êtes
allé voir le madagascar all-stars des
prêts ces derniers mois non non il
aurait dû non mais c'est pas grave c'est
une question
alors est-ce que vous avez alors chacun
des choses en préparation des avants en
préparation donc commencer par mathieu
briand se reproduit sur son des
politesses oui oui je vais entendre sa
voix la préparation - jeu
mon projet personnel est un petit peu en
stand by depuis quelques années parce
que j'essaie de me diriger plutôt vers
de l'accompagnement avec d'autres
artistes
en ce moment mais j'ai pas dis que je
laissais ça tombait je sentirai
peut-être certainement un deuxième opus
en 2018 n'ont peut-être pas aussi tôt
mais je prends le temps là pour signer
un deuxième affaire je prends le temps
l'heure le premier était et est sorti
vraiment avec beaucoup d'envié
il ya des choses qui étaient bien des
choses que je referais pas mais mais là
le deuxième je vais prendre un peu de
temps s'il d'enfer mais par contre là
j'ai et j'ai vraiment envie de
construire quelque chose avec christophe
et ludo par exemple on a en trio ludo
perez que le batteur qui veut qu 'on on
a un petit projet de deux trios sur une
musique instrumentale qu'on va mettre en
place je pense cette année même donc
c'est quelque chose qui est très concret
là et qui va être dans pour 2017 je
pense votre prochain spectacle en dehors
de ce qui va avoir du le 31 mars
alors oui j'ai effectivement c'est un
autre gros projet cette année et je
tiens on parlait aussi c'est le 22 avril
le théâtre d'un air de saint gilles sur
la scène d'ébats d'amis avec pascal
engloo donc le mans goulon le mans glou
et glou glou
c'est une super semaine qu'on va faire
on a une super équipe aussi parce qu'on
sera d'habitude on joue en trio lancera
cinq sur scène avec ludo perez donc à la
batterie bene maillot et fred piotte et
donc broc maloya à avoir vraiment
vraiment vraiment spectacle fait sa pub
et christophe de gonesse est ce qu'il ya
des projets en cours d'albums pour
l'année prochaine peut-être ou si cette
année c'est pas un projet de deuxième
album on est en cours en cours de
composition d'un rangement projet de
faire venir le pianiste aussi gerry
leonid pianiste mauricien
voilà qui est qui a remporté quand même
le festival de montreux voient pas très
connu à la réunion mais qui savait
attendu de faire connaître des gens de
la région perd album qui s'appelle the
key et voilà jazz mauricien jazz sega
donc j'essaie de faire venir en mai donc
avoir à suivre
et voilà toujours pas mal de groupes qui
nous concerne on essaie de l'éviter dans
l'émission bonne idée on essaiera horgen
zh
merci en tous les cas tous les deux donc
je rappelle ses cartes blanches sabouk
zogo project aux hommes c'est le 31 mars
à 20 heures je dis pas de bêtises à
20h06 à opale axa art saint denis bien
sûr on est debout pour ça que je pars
pas parce qu'on est debout merci d'être
venu et on écoute évidemment un petit
bout de racines pour se faire plaisir si
ce terme est rien
[Musique]
où
vous
[Musique]
m
même comment
mon habillé l'homme et la nature
[Musique]
ils vivent les douze autres victimes
sa peine son sacre la loi dalo sont
l'avenir
[Musique]
elle commence mon terrain par des athées
pas nécessaire
on dit outils massant à l'herbe
même le temps hivernal
ils ont dit si en bas du col n'est pas
aux artistes
[Musique]
mety connaîtra jamais satisfait mais
blip à tora titulaire
plus tôt
[Musique]
côté part des temps
pato
[Musique]
aucune
ce n'est pas tout
[Musique]
la cie
on
moi pour
au point
[Musique]
mon
mais
[Musique]
mais nous commençons société one happy
loin de là mais son visage au en fait à
y amène happy day à la mer
la pad dante d'idées en ôter tout ça
fait hallegatte ans
n'a pas d'un pays des intentions concept
on donne pas bon
[Musique]
mais pas audi poubelle
this orapi la scène de la filature a ni
plus ni moins
barrett la fila
elle sera foulé qui chantait
soral appli pour rafraîchir le banc pour
souffler comme l'était dès le
commencement sort apparaît dans la fin
mais pas on dit souvent mais tissot ravi
la culture première avec jean-paul menad
brocardant le fameux racines des années
80 d'un film semble que ces 89 la sortie
du morceau de tête mais enfin tu que
dans les deux années avant 88e 89e
merci m les lions paul à la précision
ont vérifié ouais on va vérifier aller
tout de suite ce matin c'est brillant
c'était brillant quand même comme
intervention pour sa bonne job morsure à
voile un jeune homme qui nous revient
avec plus de sérénité me semble-t-il
d'aller dans les sombres j'ai écouté
tendresse questionnements et amour
sebaaoui m à moi l'amour toute bonne
album rabat salé sûr il faut aimer la
côte est ou dit le film ao de son album
de laoudi elle va - oui mais il faut il
faut donner au jeu voit alors un mini
album de sept titres que donc à écouter
écouter et réécouter maintenant là j'ai
pas dire quelque chose que la changer
parce que je trouve ça déplaît beaucoup
plus doux que skoda avant bon aller mais
pas être méchant pour diane avait
beaucoup beaucoup de choses commercial
qui marchent que les jeunes aiment setra
est là mais trouve que d'un petit peu
plus abouti que contre x là pas de ragga
dance hall
il est d'ailleurs peu de pâte et de
bêtise ou rectifier un moment où son
maloya oui mais là pas de ragga
dancehall là pas de kuduro des choses
comme ça que ça se passe essayages c'est
l'âge nouvier non mais c'était un
exercice où sont tes profs et c'est le
type logiquement avait avec ça c'était
comme si tu allais que
on a des idées de fou et ça va dans tous
les sens et qui le jeune compositeur
time i donc lyn les trucs des
compositions alliés peut connaître notre
opposition comme sas cameron s'est
imposé tout ça loin et qu'on m'avait
raconté me dire ce qu'on fait et m'a
jamais fait de la trappe
oui d'accord est ce qu'on a déjà fait
non c'est quoi me connais pas et donc le
premier son cas est fait et c'était que
le premier titre autrement dans le titre
de l'album non partie des d'un style a
même expliqué me aimerait bien aussi
mais apporte un petit coup leurs mains
et ma bien aimée ne l'a en chaîne sur
les outils dont m&a - et blablabla à ces
moments un des moments de mon morceau
préféré blablabla et raymond et passe
beaucoup si sedan trentaine mais pour ce
que bloomberg est quand même différent
oui et des exercices en fait tous les
styles que mappy fait un cd voyage
vraiment vraiment différent tout dans
tout ce qui m'a pas serena la joie allez
l'amour la fête histoire tout l'est
vraiment de ceux des styles différents
donc cette année 92 des commissions donc
le lagon de la sortie autrement dit pour
l'album qui vient qu'ils soient qu'ils
m'appellent en pire que de la trappe
dessus empire eu un pays heureux ou en
pire
non non pas comme ça fait la différence
j'avais fait un peuple est récent et qui
vont s'en est aussi un album reggae qui
va sortir en milieu d'année aussi et où
les icônes là où propre et ben on verra
mais vraiment c'est nous et voulue ou
non la jna toujours des trucs qui arrive
aux dons qui plein de thèmes différents
et le reggae par rapport à la trappe
c'est vraiment des connotations et des
variants a tout fait tout les guépards
causer de ce que l'on avait causé ou
même fort sans cesse que la vidéo sortir
c'est de la trappe
quelle différence il avait gay les
voyages pas le même alors excusez moi
parce qu'il n'est pas très branché mais
la trappe c'est quoi mais ça m'a déjà
entendu mais voit pas un seul album
c'est que le morceau niqab l'arabe l'art
qui attrape ses bas
l'accord de rap avec des influences un
peu négritude de american iii si les
monnaies c'est la fois spirituelle qui
vous amène de la musique
assad à prendre à ce tome je connais ça
avec de la reynerie non le spirituel
negro spirituals complètement elle peut
tout ça j'aime beaucoup comme ça vous
avez vous avez une culture comme ça vous
non plus tôt le match est aussi
d'ailleurs
ouais l'église ça a été une première
école tout ce qui est grosse pelle et
serrage et beaucoup animé dans les
existe quand j'étais petit j'ai fait des
stages dans gars dont six aux 6 et j'ai
beaucoup baigné là dedans quand j'étais
plus jeune ça influence quelque part là
enfin votre votre propre musique à
vendre à chacun je pense oui il ya des
trous ya quelques influences quelques
touches à ce niveau là des fois dans la
musique mais qui reviennent comme ça pas
reçus par le belge a mis les musiciens
enfin je veux diriger d'instruments
guitare c'est ça non je à l'oreille
[Musique]
d'artistes réunionnais connu qu'il ne
connaît pas les nôtres et qui joue alors
la papa papa chances de réussir tout ce
qui est percussions et bon après tout ce
qui est voilà électrique
non pas que qui l'avait accompagné à
l'orgue il hésite à la ou utiliser quand
même deux autres mandats empire et
ensuite ne peuvent que remonter
depuis l'année gagné appelle rebelles ce
trésor entend bientôt sur les
photographes à sa promo dans fini
l'album l'an plein mixage que tu vas
sortir un pont du 6 mai juin et dont
l'album autrement qu'il est plein et par
ailleurs mixage et avec des ouvertures
plus grand et donc l'entrée de
la tante d'envoi de causer et c'est
vraiment des voyages est vraiment
déloyale différent et j'ai quand même
beaucoup n'ont 3,3 peu date d'un coup
enfin même c'est parce la même année
mais enfin c'est pratiquement normale
est quoi ce c'est comme une assez bonne
d'horizons différents me fais ce que
j'aime avant tout à limiter à nourrir
mais c'est le plaisir de le faire après
nous présenter jusqu'à présent même
franchement mécontent que dominés au
départ comment a commencé doucement mal
arrive comme ça avec tout le monde nous
disait moment panel est difficile ce
qu'elle est et catégoriser les jantes et
voilà un séga maloya reggae rap c'est
difficile après avec le temps va être
demandée la météo et à un peu partagé
puisque les mélange les influences de
par mes origines aux siens et c'est
vraiment un talent obadia bah oui après
tout c'est vraiment la magma sont sous
le coup c'est l'arrivée vraiment d
internet que la porte un boom mais une
explosion entre des alors justement sur
la question de l'internet parce que de
plus en plus nous les artistes
réunionnais le fond ils font la promo
sur youtube sur l'internet il vente sur
internet on ne passe plus par les
circuits classiques d'autrefois
aujourd'hui c'est incontournable pour
vous si les uns et les autres on
s'approche du micro
christophe de gonesse oui ça apporte une
visibilité indéniable ça c'est sûr donc
youtube toutes les chaînes à nogliki
dailymotion ça marche plus ça
- moi je suis moins sur dailymotion et
youtube c'est obligatoire ça c'est sûr
et du coup après on avait chacun nous
site perso je pense que oui votre propre
page facebook facebook on profite encore
un truc aussi votre compte twitter
exact où tout est relié en plus
maintenant je viens poster sur un pour
auxerre est partout un bon outil de
médiation
bonjour je pense honnêtement il ya
beaucoup de gens qui je suis a pris bon
je pense que là la communication
physique en corse et c'est toutes ces
marques
mais il ya beaucoup de gens que je
connais autour de moi qui n'utilise plus
que ça maintenant et qui fonctionne très
bien qu'ils n'utilisent plus que des
détruites ou des publications facebook
ou youtube et il se concentre
essentiellement là dessus pour
communiquer sur les événements sur leur
musique sur leurs vidéos sur leurs clips
etc
donc c'est vraiment à mon avis c'est
devenu un
à un média très très très poussée pour
pour la musique en tout cas pour les
artistes
bernard internet c'est un marché qui a
mano dans le monde de chehoudi on peut
faire beaucoup de choses via internet
mais aussi pour comme pour la musique
n'a bien s'en tirer aussi beaucoup sur
les cds ou la piraterie cela fait mal
bien bientôt de la production même
autour et les jeunes et les gens
piratent pas sur youtube on peut s'y
mêlent également maintenant apple musée
deezer spotify c'est tout est légal
points 9 euros oui d'accord mais en vain
la vidéo on peut la convertir le sont de
moins bonne qualité mais bien sûr c'est
un risque que vous prenez sachant que
quand même à côté de sa grotte du monde
nature qui regardera écoutera et
achètera il n'y a pas le choix
aujourd'hui ça c'est ça internet a
tellement bouffer tout le reste qu'on
est obligé de poster des choses des fois
libres libres de droits mais même avec
ce risque là on est obligé de le faire
sinon fonctionne pas c'est pas forcément
les cdi vont aux concerts oui raconte
est étonnamment qu arrive rue de bones
et et ce après les spectacles et j'en
achète tout de suite mais se retrouve en
magasin il fait pas parce que maintenant
aujourd'hui les nerfs et n'a même des
constructeurs de
d'ordinateur il met plus de posséder
[Musique]
tout l'effet peau que mais les
numériques lecteurs seles existe plus le
supporter possible en disparaître on
raconte on a un gros autour du vinyle et
vous y croyez je sais pas peut-être pour
le prochain album quelques années en
édition limitée à 100 exemplaires
nora beaucoup moins qu'au moins 100
exemplaires nous avons trouvé
je trouve ça bien moins le retour du
vinyle en question là je trouve ça très
très bien mais je pense que ça va être
un effet de mode comme beaucoup de
choses
vous avez connu vinyle moi j'ai connu
quelques lignes mais montrer ça a été
très court
moi pas beaucoup la casse est oui et
cassettes wall ag coûtera 7 gervais
rembobinez stylo la trentaine je n'ai
pas trop envie ni dans ceux qui ont 32
33 ans est venu pour eux c'est ses 27 28
ou 20 c'est la paléontologie gants de la
discographie de la démon discographique
ans s'écoulent que ça revienne
j'ai vu plein de chaussures sur internet
là dessus il ya des lecteurs vinyle
numérisés on en trouve ici on en parle
ici machin mais je pense que ça va être
un si juste un petit boom a un effet
boomerang juste un petit peu ça va
peut-être se tromper ça je pense alors
benjam n'a envie de revenir à l'album
autrement lui titre 7-6 3 7-6 très vite
au quai et d'une reprise oui alors
justement cette fameuse reprise pourquoi
avoir voulu parce qu'elle a eu déjà
pleine reprise de rue des machines sont
de parler comme ccc
ça coûte que meilleur au fait c'est mon
bon ça fait partie de mon billet se
passe comme tout le monde voulait aller
à côté ou bâti ce n'était pas très beau
mais ça va alors belhout est blessé on a
longtemps été des gages à monsieur
comprend pas la langue dépasser ce qui
dégage ticket véhicule en a fait depuis
son histoire tout ce qu'il fait il n'y a
pas un truc de plus il est sacré
gaillard ce que nous apprend ainsi que
de magnifiques noyau skins ou
d'égarement de l'artiste promet
d'ailleurs et à trouver des gens me sens
assez bons sur l'effort et que vous
mettez ça depuis des faits variété et
comment je dois me dit avec fermeté aux
enfants comment avons envie de faire
opposition martine a remplit déjà
trophée 2009 il reprend sa profession à
maurice les artistes internationaux
paquet tva sur moi aussi moi je mange
pas et ben me tète un parc c'était mon
coup de coeur
apparemment c'est les gens aiment et il
fait bizarre est mécontent parce que
c'est vraiment mon version kim avait
envie de partager sa patrouille à mme
lefrançois à l'article et qui sait la
composent donc l'album donc autrement c
ou uniquement on adopte avec camille
andrieu timing comique c'est enfin
content de nous donner les commandos l'a
bien trouver l'élu fait de la
composition du vin assure prenait des
idées tout en speed et ma commère
ignacio ramonet il s'est très vite donc
les super christophe secondes et vous
vous attacher les services de quelqu'un
d'autre vous composer tout oiseaux
parfois ou si vous avez des coups de
coeur comme ça généralement binchois je
compose j'arrange essaye de fait à tous
après c'est fou c'est pas évident
surtout un des fois on aimerait bien
déléguer à vue
et finalement c'est moi qui me tapent
tout vous avez les autres vous avez des
arrangeurs il ya des arrangeurs à la
ruine après quelques uns pas beaucoup
vendent pas et j'en connais un ou deux
mais peut-être qu'il y en a plus
maintenant ans dans le domaine du jazz
au feeling les arrangeurs après c'est
généralement dans le jazz si on compose
on arrange aussi enfin surfer sur marne
encaisse aussi donc pas du tout moi j'ai
gens brillants sur ma musique j'ai
rarement quelqu'un qui s'occupe de la
partie d'arrangement jeu généralement je
compose et arrange et comme je suis j'ai
le studio aussi du coup je m'occupe
aussi de la partie enregistrement
orchestrations et mixage mais comme dit
christophe dans dans ce milieu là dans
le milieu du jazz c'est très rarement
quelqu'un d'autre je pense quand même
que sur que sur ceux du jazz vocal on
peut tu as été d'ailleurs arrangeur pro
kaka pour quelqu un sur paris sur paris
a beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup de
chanteuses il ya beaucoup de chanteurs
et à mon avis ces gens là font appel à
des gens comme christophe en oisans
comme il l'a fait il ya quelques années
pour ça mais je pense que c'est dans le
jazz vocal en tant qu'instrumentiste
comme c'est le cas de christophe et moi
même on ce que généralement de notre
musique de a à z
vous êtes le sol
flûtiste de jazz à la région anon g en
me disant non pas qu'ils jouent il ya 15
mai fortis à sandra et la main je
connais pas que j'aime beaucoup qui a
son groupe soleya et qui tourne peu
entre paris et la réunion et quelques
sages et plus en live jolie d'une geôle
highway lizano griot jim célestin gym
célestin aussi l utilise alors justement
sur l'histoire du home studio vous avez
tous les trois
si tu dois vous confier de plus en plus
je veux dire les jeunes en studio et que
l'achat de christophe de gonesse de
mathieu briand en a les moyens car vous
vous avez répondu c'est vraiment moi je
peux pas faire autrement
ben en fait j'ai compris j'ai commencé
j'ai commencé par pour faire des
productions ailleurs je me suis rendu
compte qu'il fallait d un moment donné
mettre la main à la pâte pour pouvoir ce
qui est bien que le studio chez soi
c'est qu'on n'est pas limité par le
temps
alors ça peut être une problématique
aussi puisque finalement on prend son
temps et en fichent pas les choses mais
non parce que c'est un gros confort un
gros confort d'avoir son matériel par la
pression policière et claude matériel et
franchement ils sont larges volonté
l'investissement débarré et terrible
entre guillemets mais je veux dire après
c'est tellement bien rentabilisé quand
on s'y prend bien quand on est quand on
a des projets régulier que voilà avec
christophe d'ailleurs depuis que le
studio on a eu l'occasion de faire pas
mal de choses et d'ailleurs les médias
oui justement pourquoi fait il dirait du
tout aux tests tout là il faut tout ça
maintenant je suis en attendant le jazz
vocal
dd deschamps il sait qui se cache oui
oui oui je suis pas tellement courant
mais oui oui
c'est en a pas mal en chanteuse il ya en
local yahia je connais money kalimba
laurence beaumarchais
ah oui il va fourez aussi que kate et
sam entendu les premiers ça me semble
qu'ils aient qui est franchement
extraordinaire je connais quelqu'un ici
qui épure la réunion maintenant qu'ils
surent question en métropole que
gwendoline absalon ah oui en effet avec
qui j'ai participé sûr on a on a monté
un groupe s'appelait step in jazz à
l'époque ça me fait penser à ça
maintenant 2000 2005 2009 2010 était
c'était je crois que c'est mon premier
projet reprises jazz vous avez 18 ans et
ça c'était c'était un de mes tous
premiers projets d'ailleurs juste du
gone de l'insee elle écoute je sais pas
car il est super gras et je pense que là
où elle est en ce moment est le jouet le
fait de la musique et je suis très
content alors non retour jeu c'est la
question que je vais poser de christophe
gonnet safa d'honneur au tour mathieu
briand ça vous semble évident à la
réunion
tout comme cette partie un moment comme
tout comme beaucoup de règles ne va pas
vraiment pas tellement le retour de
mathieu briand c'est à dire vous n'êtes
pas parti de faire vos classes
mais manchester est en france mais tu es
jolie terme d'un parcours qui est un peu
différent fait parce qu'en fait j'ai moi
je suis papa sortie d'ici et j'ai tout
n'a jamais soit la verrerie tous en tout
cas pour l'apprentissage et pour le pour
les études non pour les études en
musique j'ai un très bon profession fait
s'appelle eric tôt av oui et quand elle
avait invité jacky mas qui m'a enseigné
tout ce que je sais aujourd'hui les gars
pour eric voilà 56 voilà pick up pour
eric et j'ai pas eu là j'ai pas eu un
jour je regrette pas mais j'aurais aimé
effectivement un moment donné dans mon
parcours partir un an ou deux ans j'ai
pas eu cette occasion parce qu'au niveau
personnel ça pas suivi soit mais c'est
pas perdu mais je pense que ça va me
faire savoir
oui il faut penser à tout ça aussi dire
entre entre lui-même et 25 ans j'aurais
aimé partir en randonnée
mais je regrette pas du tout parce qu'au
contraire j'ai une belle formation et
qu'eric et ça m'a permis d'avoir d'avoir
cette base que j'ai aujourd'hui pour
faire la musique belge à ne pas de
regret ne pas connaître la musique
palais les notes en fait face et chants
qui commence tort qu'ils reprendront la
38 40 ans et qui commence à 38,40 aussi
si beaucoup mais le temps tout comme ça
pas mal de temps
professional deux professeurs la
commettra vous avez battu à l'onf est un
peu galvaudé salle des églises
franchement fait savoir écrire et savoir
dire vous savez que c'est un plus mais
ouais en tout ce qu'on écoute sa musique
est ce que les gars je sais mais c'est
uniquement le fait des gosses et en
partager les différents fin 90 isaf et à
nous que de ça c'est mon finalement
minimes bien qu'on mesure le petit
projet là c'est là je fais peut-être
m'avancer un peu dans ce que je vais
dire la sueur mais je vais assumer
totalement ce que je veux dire je pense
que les meilleurs musiciens au monde
ceux qui ne connaissent pas la musique
en fait assez pour seulement ce que
c'est les autodidactes en fait qui ont
qui ont ce plus gros feeling la marque
par deux fois plus d'efforts peut-être
je ne sais pas mais au niveau
international il ya plein d'exemples mon
propre niveau local aussi j'accompagne
pascal manglou qui voilà qui est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on répète me dit je ne
comprends pas ce que tu me dis je tu me
parles d'accord tu me parles de notre
comprend rien et pourtant c'est l'un des
meilleurs guitaristes rock de la réunion
aïe
voilà je quand il joue on ferme sa
bouche en écoute donc c'est juste une
règle au point le manque d'eau voilà le
monde bouge et spa qui coûte 2 invité
d'ailleurs bombay jeune femme quand ça
le prochain concert là le prochain
nous attendons des sorties d'albums
quand tout cela finit pas ce que nous
fait des cancers de présentation c'est
beau c'est un concept qui existe déjà
plus longtemps mais que nous te mettre
en place ici et de gros tricks mans pour
travaille dessus c'est mes 20 ans
l'année prochaine
donc j'ai envie de tout comme jean
charles simon dire à pied est devenu fou
travail c'est un gros gros projets et
voilà pourquoi on me dit pourquoi midi
déjà parce que me rappelle quand la
première fois de devenir réunion 1ère
les commandites même pas reconnu il
était dans mon bureau et timidement
comme ça la période à la légitime meddy
gerville aussi oui mais si en ville à
l'époque bien est-il arrivé
regarde là aujourd'hui au départ comme
ça ne l'a fait c'est comme quoi ils
pensent à quelques pas de là peut être
associé à bord tout le monde contribue
tant mieux a dit voilà et puis ben
écoute un petit coup de jeune sean cinq
versions déjà les ballons
[Musique]
oh
mais chaud
[Musique]
m
le char
le pousser à
décembre
m
[Musique]
des sommes
le quesnoy
le deuxième set
[Musique]
aïe
où
[Musique]
les cultures première avec jean-paul
malades
18h56 sur red steel 2 ne soit pas là il
y avait peut-être eu un empêchement ce
sera donc pour une prochaine fois on
l'invité alors je vais préparer un petit
medley parce que j'avais trouvé l'album
de tiloun intéressant et original et
vous allez voir pourquoi
écoutez plutôt ça
[Musique]
mon
tous
vous
boum
[Musique]
on peut
en tout
[Musique]
témoin rome a new day là n'y a pas dans
les cerveaux lui même un bouc thomas
barba